cette pizza de déconfinement était très
attendue par cette mère de famille
habituée de ce restaurant situé sur la
place des manèges à versailles elle n'a
pas hésité à venir y déjeuner dès sa
réouverture
mon fils va chaque week end maintenant
on va prendre le verre on va voir la
sortie quelque chose tout coup
aujourd'hui primaire jours on avait
envie de faire ça sur cette place les
quatre restaurants ont pu rouvrir leurs
terrasses au total une centaine de
places assises entre chaque table un
mètre et demi minimum de distance toutes
les précautions sanitaires ont été
prises par le restaurateur le servir une
démarche qui pourrait servir les clients
achètent humains et non pas avoir les
masques à table bien entendu par contre
je suis rentré dans l'établissement
ils mettront des masques pour aller aux
toilettes on va éviter qu'il vient de
payer à la caisse pourra revenir à la
question directement à table
ça permet effectivement que les clients
n'est pas ton attache à déplacer et
approcher d'énergie a trop pour ce
premier jour une vingtaine de couverts
ont été réservés pour le midi escapade
en famille oppose avant de retourner au
travail toutes les occasions étaient
bonnes pour retrouver les sensations
d'un déjeuner en terrasse
pour moi c'est le synonyme de l'été qui
revient défendre pour retrouver ses amis
dans des endroits conviviaux
une fois qu'on a épuisé toutes les
recettes en fait de mousse au chocolat
et de tarte aux pommes
on a vite envie de recommencer à manger
normalement ainsi à montigny le
bretonneux on s'active pour que tout
soit prêt mercredi à 17 heures pour
l'ouverture de la terrasse
l'équipe du bistrot du théâtre a préféré
ouvrir un jour plus tard afin que les
clients soient accueillis dans de
meilleures conditions
on a laissé le dernier week-end à notre
personnel qui voit là comme chacun sait
c'est important de rattaquer avec des
idées et des défis zhixin on va
s'étendre un peu de chaque côté de notre
établissement est certainement utiliser
les trois places de parking devant
devant notre établissement sous réserve
d'autorisation de la municipalité une
centaine de places pourra ainsi être
disponibles pour la clientèle tout en
respectant les règles de distanciation
concernant la restauration elle sera
proposée dans cet établissement un des
meubles y joint